Hello friends.
Today, we're going to learn what the basic emotions are in a very fun way.
Let me introduce to you the emotions wheel.
We're going to spin the wheel to see which emotions come up...
...and we'll uncover their names.
Let's go for it.
This boy looks very happy.
Let's see which emotion this is.
Happiness.
We feel happiness when good things happen to us and we live pleasant moments.
When do you feel happy?
I feel happy when I play with my cousins on holidays.
Happiness.
Let's spin the wheel again.
This girl doesn't seem to be very happy and she's crying.
Let's uncover which emotion this is.
Sadness.
We feel sadness when something bad happens to us.
When was the last time you felt sad?
I felt very sad when I lost my favorite toy.
Sadness.
Let's spin the wheel again.
This boy seems to be afraid.
Let's see which emotion this is.
Fear.
We feel fear when we think we're in danger or something bad can happen.
What are you afraid of?
I used to be afraid of being alone in a dark place, but not anymore.
Fear.